my friend daniel jeremiah a co-host
along with bucky brooks of the move the
six podcast that's must listen to and
everything that he says on nfl network
also the radio voice with matt money
smith locally here in los angeles of the
los angeles chargers how are you dj
i'm doing great rich what's going on man
what did you think of last night's
monday night football game daniel what
do you take from i was very i was very
thankful for the uh the peyton eli watch
last night um that was like that's why
that broadcast
is perfect because you can get kind of a
stinker of a game and yet it's still
entertaining just listen to those guys
especially when drew brees got on there
just telling stories tom was great when
he was on there so i was much more
entertained by the conversation that i
was whatever was taking place on the
field how do you think defensive players
take uh tom calling him like uh dogs
chasing uh
wanted chasing a car or a meat truck or
something like that
an offensive guy i loved it because i
thought it was hilarious um we used to
always joke in draft meetings rich we'd
be in there
and uh like you'd be talking about a
defensive lineman
and a scout might go uh
you know oh you know but we have some
you know there's some questions about
his you know learning issues or you know
intelligence instead or the other and i
remember uh one of the old scouts in the
room saying look it's it's shade right
shade left get up the field it ain't
that hard okay let's not let's not
pretend like we need to have albert
einstein playing defensive line now
yeah
and uh what do you think what do you
think jeff saturday thinks uh when he
hears um
manning say he'd like the double tap
yeah the double butt tap he liked the
double butt tap in a uh in a silent snap
count
what'd you think
wherever saturday was sitting i i think
it was probably a subtle chuckle uh i
think you probably got a little chuckle
out of that so where did the scene was i
mean are we crazy that was better than
the game yeah
you know what um it i i do love the
manning cast daniel i i really do uh my
kids missed it too they were like oh
they're back on you know like they came
strolling into into the room and
marshawn lynch dropped an f-bomb yeah he
did
i mean marshawn did drop the f-bomb so
that these things happen uh when you put
marsha on live television i mean of
course
but uh so so that's your that's your
motive of viewing choice during monday
yeah yeah no i've enjoyed that no i
missed the i'm always picking up my son
from junior high football so i always
missed the first a good portion of the
first half of the game so i missed the
marshawn stuff
but then i got in and watched the rest
probably good because my wife probably i
probably got vetoed on that earmuffs
earmuffs
yes earmuffs and skittles when he was on
so
where do the saints go from here um i i
said to open the show that
um the fact that they're foreign to
everything that they've gone through
um and with michael thomas we assume on
the horizon to return
i still i still don't know what they're
you know what they are on offense with
just jameis dumping it off to camaro
that's that's unstoppable it seemed last
night what what is your more eye on the
sky all 22 assessment of what the saints
are and who they are well i i think they
they are still a dangerous team and i
think you saw you know davenport
i thought was impressive last night uh
with his speed power combination we know
what cam jordan is
um i think gosh i think pasano had a
sack
they've got a chance to have a defensive
front that can kind of they can keep you
in just about every game uh so that's
encouraging from that side of things and
and you hope michael thomas gets back
you have just enough offense now i i
don't think if they were to find
themselves in shootouts with the you
know the cowboys or the bucks
and a postseason atmosphere that that's
going to end well for them but i i don't
think they're going to play many
shootouts i think their defense has a
chance to keep them in just about every
game i still think the bucks are the
class
uh you know of that division but i think
the saints can be a playoff team it's
not going to be as easy on the eyes as
it's been in years past drew brees but
um
that's sean payton that's why he's a
good coach he's finding a different
formula to win games and the seahawks
daniel what's their way out i guess here
um they got jacksonville and then a bye
and then hopefully russ returns
and they go into the final half of the
regular season at three and five and a
division
topped by a team that's currently
five games in front of them
seven games and what what's what's your
assessment of the seahawks here
well they're not winning the division
that ship sailed um but
i i don't know without russell wilson
and we can just kind of say flippantly
well okay you beat the jags i i don't
think that's a done deal i think the
jags are coming off a bite right because
they were just in london
so they'll be coming off a bye they'll
be rested
the jags with if you take russell wilson
out of the equation i can make a strong
argument the jags are a more talented
team than the seahawks
russell wilson has russell wilson has
been
um you know i always use the phrase like
the febreze like he's just kind of made
all that other smell go away um on their
roster and now you take him out of there
it's it's a chore i mean get the one big
play to dk metcalf but it's a chore for
them getting first downs the roster's
not very good
um and you know that's why i wouldn't
give them that jags game and you come
out of that thing now you're what would
that make two and six
uh i mean that's a you you're gonna have
to play darn near flawless when when he
comes back uh to get where you need to
be i mean i just that's gonna be
difficult daniel jeremiah here on the
rich eisen show what have the bengals
done building a roster what they what
have they done that can be a blueprint
let's just say for my jets uh or anybody
else or the lions any team that's that
supposedly is snake bit
and has institutional managerial
problems that they can't get past or
some sort of bugaboo that the bengals
clearly are on the other side of right
now what have they done
daniel well
well first of all they've picked high
for a very long time right um and
similar to the cleveland browns right
eventually you're just going to
overwhelm people because you're going to
have talent you're going to have premier
players at the premier positions
joe burrow is
everything and more you know what we
thought he was going to be he's just a
he's an assassin man
so you've got him we always talk about
with offense you look at those three p's
right you look at protection yeah you
look at playmakers you look at play
callers to put that around your
quarterback i think they've got a really
good play caller
who brings in a tried and true system i
think they've done a nice job with that
offensive line it's not where it needs
to be yet
but they've they've made some upgrades
over the last few years they've gotten
better there
and then you i mean you've got a premier
young quarterback and the premier
young receiver in the nfl i mean he's
jamar chase is a absolute freak show
so um and then you met you you've got a
big time back
so they've surrounded him with a lot of
skill talent so when i look at them and
then you go to the defensive side of the
ball um you know they've they've got
good solid defensive front with some
with some edge rushers you know jesse
bates really good safety
so that's kind of how they've done it
now if you look at the jets
it's tbd on the quarterback i still
think he's got i you know that game last
week you played like 12 snaps or
whatever 12 dropbacks when i watched all
the tape he did some good things in
there
but they need to give him a lot more
help up front they are not good at all
especially without mckay beckton um so
they've got to get better there and they
need to get him a true you know a true
number one type receiver corey davis is
a nice number two i think elijah moore's
got a chance to be a good player
um but but that's the other area on that
and then on the defensive side of the
ball i mean
they were going to be a front to back
defense and you lose carl lawson who was
your your best pass rusher and i don't
think the interior guys are quite
playing up to their capabilities right
now so that's that's where those issues
are and they're so young uh in the
secondary you know that that's going to
get exposed if you're not getting
pressure up front and it surely did the
other day well i mean you mentioned
burro being an assassin i mean 400 yards
passing against the defense that made
justin herbert as marshall falk used the
line here last week turned herbert into
a bear
is what he said this is one of my
favorite lines i've heard
so uh i i i guess you know and you saw
that firsthand with what happened to the
chargers in baltimore so
what what when you said i didn't
understand that rich i still don't
understand that like i i came into that
game and i watched the tape of the
ravens defense and i watched derek carr
torch him and then i watched carson
wentz torched them
and then coming to that game and i
thought i thought herbert would go off
and the chargers passing it would go off
and it just didn't they just had a
clunker of a game and then you come out
the next week and joe burrow torches
them so i i think the ravens have major
issues in their secondary and for you
know for some reason the chargers just
weren't able to capitalize on it that
day
daniel jeremiah here on the rich eisen
show so the chargers are now
coming off of their buy taking on new
england and the raiders uh
you know i always that's what i said as
soon as this whole thing with gruden
happen hashtag let mayo cook
they they put in rich versace and
they're they seem better they seem
better do they
do they seem like the best team um in
the afc west to you the raiders they
they are playing they are playing at a
very high level right now rich you know
i i
you know i'm it's hard for me to say to
the best because i was in the building
when the when the chargers got after him
but the uh
the way that they are playing the last
two weeks i think this is officially
derek carr's team you know as long as
gruden was there he was gonna be the
face of the raiders that's john gruden's
team
and i was anxious to see how derek would
take that as this basically
he's been handed the keys to the car no
pun intended and he's been
he's played as good the last two weeks
as i've ever seen him play i mean he's
having a good year he's taking it to a
whole new level um his just confidence
that he's playing with
you know the understanding um the the
accuracy everything he's done has been
outstanding so if he's playing like that
yeah i mean they are they're not just a
contender inside the division they're a
contender much beyond that so
um that that's been uh that's been
impressive to see how they've handled
that and i think there is kind of a
you know with gruden you get some of the
genius uh aspect of it but you also get
a lot of chaos and a lot of tension
um and i think and not even talking
about what happened in this whole
episode i'm just saying just his he's a
tornado and now i think it's a very
calming atmosphere with versace in
charge and i think we've seen that a lot
of guys you know prefer that prefer that
environment and they're thriving what
about x's and o's what about all 22 how
are they is it different without gruden
and it's uh greg olsen calling the plays
here
yeah i haven't seen i have to look at
the next gen stat numbers to get it
confirmed but it seems to me like
there's a little less
uh
shifting and and motioning and you know
they've kind of dialed some of that
stuff back a little bit
um you know there's ways that they'll
actually give you the numbers on that
that's a good idea i'll look that up
okay but everything just seems to be a
little bit simplified i think you know i
heard david carr talking about that the
other day yeah and his observations
talking about how they've they've made
things a little simpler um for everybody
to play faster
and that shows up when you watch when
you watch the tape i just thought it was
just you know the ball's coming out he
knows exactly where to go and
it's just really really efficient so and
to do that without waller who's the best
offensive player
um even more impressive a few more
minutes left with daniel jeremiah here
on the rich eisen show so davonte adams
is apparently
um in danger of missing thursday night
football having tested positive for
covid um all reports are that he is
fully vaccinated so it could be just he
needs two negative tests
it looks doubtful let's just put it that
way as somebody who's had a breakthrough
case myself um how does that affect
things how do you think thursday night
football plays out now that we're
looking over the steering wheel to week
number eight and this is this could be
eventually the difference as to who
hosts a championship game and who does
not depending on how everything breaks
clearly yeah i mean everything kind of
points towards the cardinals and i i
picked the cardinals in in this when he
had to turn those in
um and then which by the way i'm gonna
tell you a great predicting score story
right after this but um i uh
i just i get this thought though rich
you know you know aaron rodgers i mean
is there it's almost like
there's times where he's so good he can
get a little bored
i almost think this one it's like it's
almost like he's gonna you know tie one
arm behind his back no devonte adams
then let me just go show you guys how
good i am i'm gonna go out here and beat
the undefeated arizona cardinals on the
road i mean it feels like we're kind of
set up for that yeah well i mean
chandler jones is coming back i i mean
that that would be a heck of a unit to
do it in front of because i i i think
i'm through and j.j watt could be picked
up on an nfl film's mic
saying that he's already sick of uh the
whole concept of the cart are the
cardinals for real like damn straight
they are i mean like this is a
we wouldn't be questioning uh another
team
uh that's seven and oh i mean we're all
kind of trying to wrap our arms around
the fact that the bengals and the
cardinals are top seeded currently
through seven weeks
you are what you are as parcel said and
what these teams are are are threats
considerable threats all right can i can
i make my my picking games confession
here yes sir of course
so
uh nfl media they they uh i guess this
goes on youtube every week where and and
on the website where that's all the
quote unquote expert picks for the games
and you see these all get retweeted
after the games are over right
um well
in for it to live longer you know you
want the content to live as long as it
can it's not ever green when you're
picking games correct they want that to
go up on tuesdays
find you we haven't seen an injury
report yet like there's no way to feel
good about a selection of a sunday game
on a tuesday that's correct it's the way
the world you got to get it up
so i've got tuesdays are a busy day i've
got podcasts i've got some amazon stuff
i got some charger stuff and so i get
these emails or these text messages hey
we got to pick the games you got to pick
the games can you please pick the games
can you please turn in the game and i'm
like you know what finally the other
last week i'm like i've had enough
i said give me the cardinals 45 to 10
you can pick the rest literally
what i sent right okay yeah well my my
ghost picker picked the uh bengals to
beat the ravens which was i was the only
one out of like 15 experts to pick the
bengals to beat the ravens the bengals
account after the game shouted me out
and and thanked me for being a believer
in the cincinnati bengals turns out i
didn't even make the pick it wasn't even
me so i felt guilty i'm carrying around
all this guilt for all this love and
praise that i'm getting and it was a
ghost pick
a ghost pick i like it a ghost pick
um you wanna who who's your ghost picker
because i'd like to stop eating shop he
did a uh he did a wonderful job on that
i told him i sent him a text after the
game i also apparently picked the uh the
titans to beat the chiefs you're really
good at it man you're good at this
daniel daniel you're really really good
at this so let's be honest did you see
your picks by your ghost picker and go
what are you doing with the bengals like
did you did you think that did you at
least be totally honest with you rich
the first time i was aware that i had
picked the bengals when the bengals
account
last one for you daniel do you think the
guy who got the uh the mike evans handed
the uh the football to the 600th
touchdown pass of brady's career
football too do you think he should have
held out for more like brockman and tj
here think that he should have gotten
ahead and tom brady by the way thinks
that yeah
oh my gosh
i'm just i'm just imagining little
brockman on christmas opening up his
presence with a frown on his face that
he didn't get you know five nintendo
games that he thought he deserved like
that's coming let's stop being greedy
here let's just be thankful yes that's a
good deal that's a lot he took away from
that and and and he doesn't have the
animus of his favorite player i mean you
go out there and you ask for too much
like how would you like to live the rest
of your life as a bucks fan knowing that
tom brady thinks you're a jerk
great question daniel that's that's what
i said yesterday this is before i found
out he got a bitcoin too a bitcoin yeah
i mean come on now 3k i i had to
actually look that up what a bitcoin
cost i had to look that one up rich is
hip dj um what seriously you guys know
exactly down how how much a bitcoin is
you guys know that i checked that price
15 times why do you have one yeah
jeez
two salud hey okay very good
you don't have one tj right okay delta i
do not i am invested in uh i'm invested
in some uh cryptocurrency
i've got
uh stock which is uh like some type of a
crypto thing that's okay they couldn't
trust you you've ever been on that's the
trust dj you're good okay very good yeah
i have some coins from europe okay there
you go
you got a
[Laughter]
dude in tampa's got a bitcoin tj's got a
euro there you go that's your that's
your up to speed all right uh uh hey man
uh congrats on your great bengals pick
uh very proud of you very proud of you a
lot of research a lot of research a lot
of study and that's what separates the
men from the boys take care of yourself
daniel jeremiah thanks for the call
thanks guys you bet check out move the
sticks the podcast with daniel jeremiah
and bucky brooks then of course the
twitter account instagram account at
move the sticks for dj right here on the
rich eisen show hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here